la continuación de un largo y doloroso
proceso judicial se trata del juicio
contra nicolás cruz por el tiroteo
masivo en una escuela de parque la
florida el 14 de febrero de 2018 el
joven de entonces 19 años regresó a la
escuela de secundaria marjorie ty stone
man douglas tea que había sido
expulsados meses antes por problemas de
conducta y abrió fuego con un rifle
semiautomático durante casi seis minutos
asesinando a 14 estudiantes y 3
empleados e hiriendo a otros 17 después
salió del edificio sin ser detectado y
fue arrestado una hora más tarde
caminando por una calle residencial
parkland fue uno de los tiroteos masivos
más mortíferos en eeuu y nunca antes un
tirador masivo en el país había
sobrevivido para enfrentar los cargos su
destino está ahora en manos de un jurado
cuyos miembros decidirán si merece la
pena de muerte o si pasará el resto de
su vida en prisión cruz se declaró
culpable en octubre de 17 cargos de
asesinato en primer grado en los últimos
años emitió varias misivas a los
familiares de las víctimas pidiendo
perdón una comisión de investigación
estatal descubrió fallas de las
autoridades policiales el día del
tiroteo incluso el fbi fue acusado y
tuvo que indemnizar
víctimas puesto que varias pistas como
su fascinación por las armas y
advertencias de personas cercanas al
asesino indicaban que cruz tenía
intención de atacar el tiroteo e inició
un movimiento nacional de control de
armas que se extiende hasta hoy
tenemos que hacer más que eso ya hemos
pasado por esto durante años y años
y es que este tipo de tiroteos masivos
contra escuelas se cierran sucediendo en
eeuu el último el 24 de mayo en oval de
texas una masacre que acabó con la vida
de 19 estudiantes y los maestros